[Music]
hello there good evening you're watching
the Press preview it's a first look at
what is on the front pages as they
arrive in the next half an hour we're
going to be seeing what is making the
headlines of those Sunday papers that is
with Claire Ellicott acting Deputy
political editor of the mail on Sunday
and Nancy Fielder editor-in-chief of
national world cities so let's take a
look at what is on some of those front
pages
or the Sunday Express hears that Liz
truss is insisting conservative MPS stop
worrying about internal party strife
the Sunday Telegraph takes the same
angle their headline trust tells MPS
unite or face disaster
one of the prime minister's key Tori
detractors that is the former cabinet
minister Michael Gove comes in for heavy
criticism in the mail on Sunday
and the Observer describes the
destruction of the Kirch Bridge linking
Crimea to the Russian Mainland as a
bitter blow to Vladimir Putin well on
that same story the Sunday Times
declares Bridge blast opens up Crimea
a poll cited by Scotland on Sunday
suggests that the majority of those
surveyed don't believe the next general
election will act as a de facto
referendum on Independence
and the Sunday people reports on the
death of the serial killer Peter Tobin
the Sunday Mirror Has spoken to Mr
Tobin's ex-wife
and the sun has a story concerning the
former Strictly Come Dancing
professional AJ Pritchard
and the star has word of an embarrassing
on-stage incident for the former Star
Trek actor William Shatner
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out all of
those front pages of the Sunday papers
while you sit and watch us discuss them
well we're joined tonight by Claire
Ellicott and Nancy Fielder are really
good to see you both thank you for
giving up your Saturday night to join us
here on Sky News no surprises is it
ahead of MPS going back to Parliament
that we've got politics stories and a
lot of disunity on the front of the
papers
um let's start with you Claire with
these Sunday
Telegraph truss tells MPS unite or face
disaster she's had a pretty bumpy start
hasn't she to her Premiership and now
she needs to get some order
well certainly so we've just come back
from the Tory conference and a bit of a
difficult ride for her and now she's set
to tell uh latorium he's when she gets
back to Parliament when Parliament
Returns on Tuesday that they need to
unite behind her or face and a kissed
armor and SNP Coalition now she's going
to she's already had real problems with
um having to U-turn over the top rate of
attack
and she's almost certainly going to face
more problems with the disability Rao
she's you know people were openly
plotting at Tory conference she's got
Michael Gove Grant shafts she's going to
have some real issues when she gets back
and and some real difficulty controlling
many of her rest of MPS yeah what do you
think Nancy I mean in some ways it's not
surprising is it because only a third of
Tory MPS supported her in the first
place
it's not surprising but it's so
depressing I mean we're talking about
lowering the happiness levels on a
Saturday night but this is a party that
just isn't capable of uniting no matter
who the prime minister is and we've seen
this time and time again and we've had
politicians who've been put put in
charge May prime minister again we're
facing it right now nobody in the
country has voted for them except for
this very small group of people who
don't even seem to like we're in a
ludicrous situation is not perhaps the
party facing disaster we should be
worried about it's the country facing
disaster we're in an absolutely awful
position being led by somebody who even
the small amount of people who voted for
who don't want is ludicrous well it's
also on the front page of the Sunday
Express isn't it Claire and it's really
speaking to the Liz truss approach to
leadership here heads down and charge
she wants to ignore all of the dissent
and just get on with trying to
kick-start the economy
yes this does seem to be a bit of a
theme with less trust she's come into
power she's she's got the support of a
third of the MPS she's sort of continued
on with her mini budget despite the fact
that wasn't in the Tory Manifesto and
she she's going to have some real
problems but her approach so far has
been
um to carry on regardless and she's she
has I mean she has had to U-turn over
the 45p top rate of tax and the the rare
over benefits is going to be an issue
but you know she she has shown so far
that she is quite belligerent and
determined to you know win over her MPS
how far do you think she'd go on that
Claire I mean in order to you know get
some bang some discipline into her party
do you think we could see her taking the
whip off people who dissent
well um so Jake Barry the party
Chairman's been pretty strong on this he
said that any MPS who who sort of don't
vote in life of the government may have
the whip taken off them this is quite as
quite a bold thing to do at the moment
and there's a lot of rest of MPS they're
not necessarily
um in the mood to sort of go along with
what with what the government is saying
um and that message is is quite a tough
one I was speaking to one Tory MP who
said that actually they you know they
really should should be showing just
immense amounts of compassion as opposed
to trying to sort of force these things
through and like we I said we've already
seen one U-Turn when it will always come
down through arithmetic and the fact is
is she doesn't have the numbers to get
some of these votes through she's going
to have to sort of and back off a bit
um let's talk shall we uh Nancy about
Michael Gove I'm not sure what the
opposite of King maker is but it seems
to be his job description doesn't it and
reported that he was the one that went
into Boris Johnson to say to him uh on
that last day you know the games up mate
and now he's been very outspoken hasn't
he about
um particularly this 45p rate of tax uh
does it matter
can he do the same damage to her
well I think he probably can and she
clearly believes that he can because
according to the Mail article she
invited him and spent 45 minutes while
the country is on its knees and falling
further down 45 minutes having a cup of
tea with Michael Gove trying to persuade
him that he should be on her side and
that the party should unite and all the
things we've just been talking about and
then clearly it just went and stabbed
her in the back so it was a complete
waste of 45 minutes of the prime
minister's time but I mean who he does
seem to be incredibly powerful even when
not really in great positions of power
within the government it is
extraordinary the power that he wields
um and you would think perhaps it would
be the Prime Minister who would have
that power yeah it doesn't seem to be
but it is it is all down to the numbers
that we know what she wants to do is
keep a job it's not really about making
things equal in the country and making
sure that people can pay their bills
keep their mortgages not end up homeless
all these sort of things don't seem to
be the priority it's all about the
conservative party it infighting and
it's it's really sad that we're at this
point but we seem to have been at this
point for a few years to be honest well
the male making it pretty clear
um that they don't seem to be too
positive on Michael Gover quoting a
number 10 aide saying he's sadistic
Claire
um
well I mean we've seen I think it was
about nine different fringes he did at
the toy Party Conference
um in which he he didn't mince his words
he really he really sort of let rip and
a lot of Liz truss's allies have blamed
him for being the ringleader
um in in securing the um u-turn on the
45p rate of tax and there's now no
secret that Michael Gove backed Rishi
sunak he is not in favor of of Liz truss
um being in charge and there's um in
this piece in the mail on Sunday there's
a suggestion that she dangled a
diplomatic job in front of him but um he
seems not to have taken that
um taken that sort of hint and has gone
to a Tory conference nonetheless and and
um openly criticized her yeah you wonder
whether she regrets perhaps um you know
not having him in cabinet what do you
think
well um I don't think Michael Gove would
have served in the cabinet he was he
obviously came out for
um he obviously came up for us she's
like towards the end of the leadership
race and um had kept quiet
um before that but Liz trusted his
allies to sort of been blaming him for a
lot of the of the briefing against her
and he backed Kevin off initially many
saw him as just being an outrider for
issue soon acculator he later said that
you know he would back the former
Chancellor so it's not a happy
relationship and um I suspect yeah he he
knew he wouldn't get a job well she's
got a work cut out for her hasn't she
from next week um also we haven't had
time to talk about it but the time
Sunday Times also reporting that she's
set to make another u-turn on the
benefits rise as well plenty for us to
talk about
um after the break coming up as well a
bridge too dangerous it's another
problem for Putin as his forces struggle
against Ukraine's fight back we'll be
talking about that as well after the
break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me again our Claire
Ellicott and Nancy Fielder
um hello again both of you let's talk
about these incredible images on the
front of many of the papers of course
this bridge which annexed Crimea that
became effectively a hated symbol of
Russian occupation didn't it for the
ukrainians and I wonder uh Nancy whether
these images are going to really be the
image that speaks to the real turning
point in this war what do you think
I think we all hope it is a turning
point in the war
um I mean the experts seem to think it's
a massive massive step forward but
perhaps not a turning point but I mean a
striking images go you're going to
struggle to beat it aren't you and
they're used to sort of really high
impact and good effect on a couple of
the front pages for tomorrow I mean they
haven't destroyed the bridge the bridge
hasn't completely crumbled but it is a
massive massive blow and we all saw the
footage of Putin sort of driving himself
along with the sort of the first car to
cross it when it was built and how much
it meant to him and his ego and his
whole drive to invade and take over
other countries at any cost so this is a
massive celebration of the Ukraine and
we'll want it to be a step closer to the
end don't we yeah and and Claire the
question is I suppose given his personal
attachment to this bridge coming under
attack almost as a as a birthday
Memento for him um what happened next
you think what do you think how is he
going to respond
well this is a great warrior isn't that
we we do keep hearing President Biden in
the U.S talking about nuclear Armageddon
and there are great fears about what
Peter will do because the ukrainians
have made incredible increases into um
the territory that Russia invaded and I
think we're all you know desperately
hoping that continues but Russia is a is
a huge threat to the west to Ukraine and
um I think there is a huge concern about
what President Putin may be capable of
yeah indeed um well I'm going to take us
on a little bit
of a handbrake turn now there's plenty
more we could get into about Ukraine but
uh fly tipping Nancy up by 40 as trivial
fines fail to deter it what's going on
that's right so in the last 10 years
um the incidence of fly tipping have
absolutely soared and they're well over
a million now and I think it is
something that bothers a lot of us
because you only you don't have to go
very far to see sort of sacks of rubbish
dumped fridges wardrobes anything really
and now the government is saying it's
going to do a big Crackdown on it that
it's the councils haven't done well
enough in tackling it but let's not
forget that actually the councils have
all had their own funding massively
massively slashed and that has led to
tips that have less hours to charging
more to get your fridge picked up when
instant just just a couple of rows away
from where I live where three fridges
were done somebody had clearly paid
somebody else to pick them up cheaper
than it costs for the accounts to pick
them up and get rid of them so this
isn't an easy one for the government to
say oh this is terrible councils need to
do more more needs to be done but it
costs money doesn't it and at the end of
the day we don't seem to have a lot of
money but it's really really important I
mean at the end actually at the end of
the day it's people's disgusting
behavior isn't it it's not acceptable
there are places to take it and
everybody needs to take more
responsibility for the places where they
live and keeping them looking nice yeah
and two pounds 50 isn't going to be
enough of a deterrent is it Claire to
stop the disgusting Behavior as Nancy
calls it
no certainly not I mean there is there
is sort of a real raw Brewing on the
environment at the moment and we've got
the cost of living crisis and you know
worries about energy and I think there's
trust some of the some of the policies
she's sort of championing uh are of
concern to a lot of environmental groups
we've had the rspb and I think National
Trust are a sort of agitating against it
um I think it's going to be a real flash
point in coming weeks as to what